[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ton capitaine retardataire qui
attend la baby-sitter qui attend quel
soldat Dawson qui diable est le privé
Doss Je rêvais d'être médecin
mais euh ne va pas beaucoup à l'école
Je ne peux pas rester ici pendant qu'ils vont tous se
battre pour moi  ce que vous pensez que cette
guerre va correspondre à vos idées pendant que
tout le monde prend la vie je
vais la sauver ce sera ma façon de
servir c'est un cadeau personnel du
gouvernement des États-Unis conçu pour les
amener à l'ennemi
Eh bien, je suis désolé, sergent, je ne peux pas toucher une arme à feu, vous ne tuez pas, non, monsieur, vous savez qu'il y a pas mal de meurtres qui se produisent pendant la guerre.
ne pense pas que ce soit une question de
religion je pense que c'est une planète molle
avec toi parce que tu n'étais comme personne d'
autre ils disent que tu pourrais aller en
prison je ne sais pas comment je vais vivre
pour moi si je meurs
J'étais en train de rêver ce que je crois avec le monde si déterminé à
se déchirer  ça ne me semble pas
une si mauvaise chose de vouloir en reconstituer un
peu, une dose privée,
vous êtes libre de courir dans l'
enfer une bataille sans une seule
arme pour vous protéger
[Musique]
Je vais t'avoir  home
il y a quelque chose que tu dois voir
Je l'ai fait donc la voiture
mais si je remonte jusqu'à maintenant
et puis je vais monter là-haut sans
toi
[Musique]
Oh Dieu fais-moi confiance
tu ferais mieux de venir me
voir  Seigneur,
aide-moi à en avoir un de plus
[Musique]